you're one of the world-class
researchers in reinforcement learning
deep reinforcement learning
certainly in the robotics space what is
reinforcement learning
i think that what reinforcement learning
refers to today is really just
the kind of the modern incarnation of
learning based control so classically
reinforcement learning has a much more
narrow definition which is that
it's you know literally learning from
reinforcement like the thing does
something and then it gets a reward
or punishment but really i think the way
the term is used today is
it's used to refer more broadly to
learning based control
so some kind of system that's supposed
to be controlling something
and it uses data to get better and what
does control mean so this action
is the fundamental element yeah it means
making rational decisions
right and rational decisions are
decisions that maximize a measure of
utility
and sequentially so you made decisions
time and time and time again
now like so it's easier to see that kind
of
idea in the space of maybe games and the
space of robotics
do you see it bigger than that is it
applicable
like were were the limits of the
applicability of reinforcement learning
yeah so rational decision making is
essentially the
the encapsulation of the ai problem
viewed
through a particular lens so any problem
that we would want
a machine to do an intelligent machine
can likely be represented as a
decision-making problem
classifying images is a decision-making
problem although
not a sequential one typically uh you
know controlling
a chemical plant as a decision-making
problem deciding what videos to
recommend
on youtube is a decision making problem
and one of the really appealing things
about
reinforcement learning is if it does
encapsulate
the range of all these decision making
problems perhaps working on
reinforcement learning is
you know one of the ways to reach a very
broad swath of ai problems
but what what do you use the fundamental
difference between reinforcement
learning and
maybe supervised machine learning so
reinforcement learning can be viewed as
a generalization of supervised machine
learning
you can certainly cast supervised
learning as a reinforcement learning
problem you can just say your loss
function is
the negative of your reward but you have
stronger assumptions you have the
assumption that someone actually
told you what the correct answer was
that your data was iid
and so on so you could view
reinforcement learning essentially
relaxing some of those assumptions
now that's not always a very productive
way to look at it because if you
actually have a supervised learning
problem
you'll probably solve it much more
effectively by using supervised learning
methods
because it's easier but uh you can view
reinforcement as a generalization of
that no for sure but
they're fundamentally different that's a
mathematical statement that's absolutely
correct
but it seems that reinforcement learning
the kind of tools we'll bring to the
table today
of today so maybe down the line
everything will be a reinforcement
learning problem just like you said
image classification should be mapped to
a reinforcement learning problem but
today
the tools and ideas the way we think
about them are are different
sort of supervised learning has been
used very effectively to solve
basic narrow ai problems reinforcement
learning kind of represents
the dream of ai it's uh very much so
in the research space now in sort of
captivating the imagination of people of
what we can do with intelligent systems
but it hasn't yet had as wide of an
impact as the supervised learning
approaches so that
sort of my question comes from the more
practical sense like what do you see is
the
gap between the more general
reinforcement learning
and the very specific yes the sequential
decision making with one sequence
one step in the sequence of the
supervised learning
so from a practical standpoint i think
that one
one thing that is uh you know
potentially a little tough now and this
is i think something that we'll see
this is a gap that we might see closing
over the next couple of years
is the ability of reinforcement learning
algorithms to effectively utilize
large amounts of prior data so one of
the reasons why it's a bit difficult
today
to use reinforcement learning for all
the things that we might want to use it
for
is that in most of the settings where we
want to do rational decision making
it's a little bit tough to just deploy
some policy that
does crazy stuff and learns purely
through trial and error
it's much easier to collect a lot of
data a lot of logs of
some other policy that you've got and
then maybe
you you know if you can get a good
policy out of that then you deploy it
and let it kind of fine-tune a little
bit
but algorithmically it's quite difficult
to do that so i think that once we
figure out how to
get reinforcement learning to bootstrap
effectively from large data sets
then we'll see a very very rapid growth
in applications of these technologies so
this is what's referred to as off policy
reinforcement learning or
offline rl or batch rl and i think we're
seeing a lot of
research right now that that's bringing
us closer and closer to that
can you maybe paint the picture of the
different methods she said
off policy what's value-based
reinforcement learning what's
policy-based what's model based what's
off policy on policy what are the
different categories of reinforcement
yeah so one way we can think about
reinforcement learning is that
it's um it's in some very fundamental
way
it's about learning models that can
answer kind of
what if questions so what would happen
if i take this action that i hadn't
taken before
and you do that of course from
experience from data and oftentimes you
do it in a loop
so you build a model that answers these
what-if questions
use it to figure out the best action you
can take and then go and try taking that
and see if the outcome agrees with what
you predicted
so the different kinds of techniques
basically refer to different ways of
doing it so model-based methods
answer a question of uh what state you
would get
basically what would happen to the world
if you were to take a certain action
value based methods
they answer the question of what value
you would get meaning what utility you
would get
but in a sense they're not really all
that different because they're both
really just answering these what-if
questions
now unfortunately for us with current
machine learning methods answering
what-if questions can be really hard
because they are really questions about
things that didn't happen
if you want to answer what if questions
about things that did happen you
wouldn't need to learn model you would
just like repeat the thing that worked
before
and that's really a big part of why url
is a little bit tough
so if you have a purely on-policy kind
of online process
then you ask these what-if questions you
make some mistakes then you go and try
doing those
mistaken things and then you observe
kind of the counter examples that will
teach you not to do those things again
if you have a bunch of off policy data
and you just want to synthesize the best
policy you can out of that data then you
really have to deal with the
the challenges of making these these
counter factors first of all what's a
policy
yeah a policy is a
a model or some kind of function that
maps from
observations of the world to actions so
in reinforcement learning we often refer
to the
the current configuration of the world
as the state so we say the state kind of
encompasses everything you need to fully
define
where the world is at at the moment and
depending on how we formulate the
problem we might say you either get to
see the state
or you get to see an observation which
is some snapshots and piece of the state
so policy is just includes everything in
it
in order to be able to act in this world
yes and so
what does off policy mean if so yeah so
the terms on policy and off policy refer
to how you get your data
so if you get your data from somebody
else who was doing some other stuff
maybe you get your data from some
manually programmed
uh system that was you know just running
in the world before
that's referred to as off policy data
but if you got the data by
actually acting in the world based on
what your current policy thinks is good
we call that on-policy data
and obviously on-policy data is more
useful to you because
if your current policy makes some bad
decisions you will actually see that
those decisions are bad
off policy data however might be much
easier to obtain because maybe that's
all the log data that you have from
before
so we talked about offline talked about
autonomous vehicles so you can envision
off policy kind of approaches in
robotic spaces where there's already ton
of robots out there but they don't get
the luxury of being able to uh
explore based on a reinforcement
learning framework
so how do we make again open question
but how do we make off policy methods
work yeah so uh this is something that
has been kind of a big open problem for
a while and in the last few years
uh uh people have made a little bit of
progress on that
um you know i can tell you about and
it's not by any means solved yet but i
can tell you some of the things that um
for example we've done to try to
address some of the challenges it turns
out that one really big challenge
with off policy reinforcement learning
is that you can't really trust your
models
to give accurate predictions for any
possible action
so if i've never tried to if in my data
set i never saw somebody
steering the car off the road onto the
sidewalk
my value function or my model is
probably not going to predict the right
thing if i ask what would happen if i
were to steer the car off the road onto
the sidewalk
so one of the important things you have
to do to get off paul's crl
to work is you have to be able to figure
out whether a given action
will result in a trustworthy prediction
or not and you can use
kind of distribution estimation methods
kind of density
estimation methods to try to figure that
out so you could figure out that well
this action
my model is telling me that it's great
but it looks totally different from any
action i've taken before so my model is
probably not correct
and you can incorporate regularization
uh terms into your learning objective
that will essentially
tell you not to ask those questions that
your model is unable to answer
what would lead to breakthroughs in this
space do you think
like or what's needed is this a data set
question do we need to
collect big benchmark data sets that
allow us to explore the space
is it uh a new kinds of methodologies
like what's your sense or or maybe
coming together in a space of robotics
and defining the right problem to be
working on yeah
i think for off policy reinforcement in
particular it's very much an algorithms
question right now
and uh you know this is something that i
think is great because an algorithm's
question is
you know that that just takes some very
smart people to get together and think
about it really hard
whereas if it was like a data problem or
hardware problem that would take some
serious engineering
so that's why i'm pretty excited about
that problem because i think that we're
in a position where we can make some
real progress on it just by coming up
with the right algorithms
in terms of which algorithms they could
be um you know the problems at their
core
are very related to problems in you know
things like
like causal inference right because when
you're really dealing with is situations
where
you have a model a statistical model
that's trying to make predictions
about things that i hadn't seen before
and if it's a if it's a model that's
generalizing properly that'll make good
predictions
if it's a model that picks up on
spurious correlations that will not
generalize properly
and then you can you have an arsenal of
tools you can use you could for example
figure out
what are the regions where it's
trustworthy or on the other hand you
could try to make it generalized better
somehow or
some combination of the two is there
room for
mixing sort of uh where most of it
like 90 95 is off policy you already
have the data set
and then you get to send the robot out
to do a little exploration
like what what's that role of mixing
them together
yeah absolutely i think that this is
something that you actually uh
uh described very well at the beginning
of the of our discussion when you talk
about the iceberg
like this is the iceberg that the 99 of
your prior experience that's your
iceberg
you use that for off policy
reinforcement learning and then
of course if you've never uh you know
opened that particular kind of door with
that particular lock before
then you have to go out and fiddle with
it a little bit and that's that
additional one percent
to help you figure out a new task and i
think that's actually like a pretty good
recipe
going forward is this uh to you the most
exciting
space of reinforcement learning now or
is there what's uh
and maybe taking a step back not just
now but what's
to use the most beautiful idea i
apologize for the romanticized question
but the beautiful idea or
concept in reinforcement learning
in general i i actually think that one
of the things that is
a very beautiful idea in reinforcement
learning is just the idea that you can
obtain a near optimal controller in your
optimal policy
without actually having a complete model
of the world this is
um you know so it's something that feels
perhaps kind of obvious uh if you if you
just hear the term reinforcement
learning or you think about trial and
error learning
but from a controls perspective it's a
very weird thing because
classically uh you know we we think
about
engineered systems and controlling
engineered systems as
uh as the problem of writing down some
equations and then figuring out given
these equations
you know basically like solve for x
figure out the the thing that that
maximizes its performance and
the the theory of reinforcement learning
actually gives us a mathematically
principled framework
to think to reason about you know
optimizing some quantity
when you don't actually know the
equations that govern that system
and that to me that actually seems
kind of kind of you know very elegant
not not something that
uh sort of becomes immediately obvious
at least in the mathematical sense
does it make sense to you that it works
at all
well i think it makes sense when you
take some time to think about it but it
is a little surprising
well then then taking a step into the
more
deeper representations which is also
very surprising
of the sort of the richness
of the state space the space of
environments that
this kind of approach can operate in can
you maybe say
what is deep reinforcement learning
well deep reinforcement learning simply
refers to
taking reinforcement learning algorithms
and combining them with
high capacity neural net representations
which is
you know kind of it might at first seem
like a pretty arbitrary thing just take
these two components and stick them
together
but the reason that it's um it's
something that has become so important
in recent years is that
reinforcement learning it kind of faces
an exacerbated version of a problem that
has faced many other machine learning
techniques so
if you if we go back to like you know
the early 2000s or the late 90s
we'll see a lot of research on machine
learning methods
that have some very appealing
mathematical properties like
they reduce the convex optimization
problems for instance
but they require very special inputs
they require
a representation of the input that is
clean in some way like for example
clean in the sense that the classes in
your multi-class classification problems
separate linearly so they have some kind
it's some kind of good representation
and we call this a feature
representation
uh and for a long time people were very
worried about features in the world of
supervised learning because somebody had
to actually
build those features so you couldn't
just take an image and plug it into your
logistic regression or your
svm or something someone had to take
that image and process it using some
handwritten code
and then neural nets came along and they
could actually learn the features
and suddenly we could apply learning
directly to the raw inputs which was
great for images
but it was even more great for all the
other fields where people hadn't come up
with good features yet
and one of those fields is actually
reinforcement learning because in
reinforcement learning
the notion of features if you don't use
neural nets and you have to design your
own features
is very very opaque like it's very hard
to imagine like let's say i'm playing
chess or go what is a feature with which
i can represent the value function for
go or even
the optimal policy for go linearly like
i don't even know how to start thinking
about it and people tried all sorts of
things they would write down you know
an expert chess player looks for whether
the knight is in the middle of the board
or not so that's a feature is knight in
middle of board
and they would write these like long
lists of kind of arbitrary made up stuff
and that was really kind of getting us
nowhere but and that's a little chess is
a little more accessible than the
robotics problem absolutely
right that's there's at least experts in
the in the
different features for chess but
still like the neural network there that
to me that's i mean you put it
eloquently and almost made it seem like
a natural step to add neural networks
but the fact that neural networks are
able to discover features
in the control problem it's very
interesting it's hopeful
i'm not sure what to think about it but
it feels hopeful
that the control problem has features to
be learned
like i guess my question is
is it surprising to you how far the deep
side of deep reinforcement learning is
able to like what
the space of problems has been able to
tackle from especially in games with
the alpha star and
and uh alpha zero and just the the
representational power there
and in the robotic space and what would
what is your sense of the limits of this
representation power in the control
context i think that in regard to the
limits
a bit here i think that
one thing that makes it a little hard to
fully answer this question
is because in settings where we would
like to put
push these things to the limit we
encounter other bottlenecks
so like the reason that i can't get
uh my robot to learn how to like
i don't know do the dishes in the
kitchen it's not because it's neural net
is not big enough
it's because when you try to actually do
trial and error learning reinforcement
learning
directly in the real world where you
have the potential to gather these large
ver you know highly varied and complex
data sets you start running into other
problems
like one problem you run into very
quickly uh
it'll first sound like a very pragmatic
problem but it actually turns out to be
a pretty deep scientific problem
take the robot put in your kitchen have
it try to learn to do the dishes with
trial and error
it'll break all your dishes and then
we'll have no more dishes to clean
now you might think this is a very
practical issue but there's something to
this which is that
if you have a person trying to do this
you know a person will have some degree
of common sense they'll
break one dish they'll be a little more
careful with the next one and if they
break all of them they're gonna go and
get more or something like that so
there's all sorts of scaffolding
that um that comes very naturally to us
for our learning process like
you know if i have to learn something
through trial and error i have the
common sense to know that i have to you
know
try multiple times if i screw something
up i ask for help or i reset things or
something like that
and all that is kind of outside of the
classic reinforcement problem
formulation
there are other things that are uh that
can also be categorized as
kind of scaffolding but are very
important like for example where do you
get your reward function
if i want to learn how to pour a cup of
uh water
uh well how do i know if i've done it
correctly now that probably requires
an entire computer vision system to be
built just to determine that and that
seems a little bit inelegant
so there are all sorts of things like
this that start to come up when we
think through what we really need to get
reinforcement learning to happen at
scale in the real world
and i think that many of these things
actually suggest a little bit of a
shortcoming in the problem formulation
and a few deeper questions that we have
to resolve that's really interesting i i
talked to like david silver
uh about alpha zero and it seems like
there's no
again the the we haven't hit the limit
at all
uh in the context when there's no broken
dishes so in the
in the case of go you can it's really
about just scaling compute
so again like the bottleneck is
the amount of money you're willing to
invest in compute and then maybe
the different the scaffolding around how
difficult it is to scale compute maybe
but there there's no limit and it's
interesting now we move to the real
world and there's the broken dishes
there's all the
and the reward function like you
mentioned that's really nice so what
how do we push forward there do you
think there's there's this kind of
a sample efficiency question that people
bring up or you know not having to break
a hundred thousand dishes
is this an algorithm question is this a
data selection like question
what do you think how do we how do we
not break too many dishes
yeah um well one way we can think about
that is that
um maybe we need to
um be better at um reusing our data
building that iceberg so perhaps
perhaps it's too much to hope that you
can have a machine
that in isolation in the vacuum without
anything else
can just master complex tasks in like in
minutes the way that people do
but perhaps it also doesn't have to
perhaps what it really needs to do is
have an existence a lifetime where it
does many things and the previous things
that it has done
prepare it to do new things more
efficiently
and you know the study of these kinds of
questions typically falls under
categories like multi-task learning or
meta-learning
but they all fundamentally deal with the
same general
theme which is use experience for doing
other things
to learn to do new things efficiently
and quickly
you